winter is coming and that which is dead
may never die home second episode of the
sixth season of Game of Thrones please
keep in mind
I don't do spoiler free any more
spoilers will abound this is an episode
that has some moments that I really
loved and some that I really be there
could have done without or just did
nothing for me so a bit of a mixed bag
on this one that said what's good I
really liked I liked seeing the wildling
show up at Castle black and just
immediately take control I love the
giant just grabbing the guy against the
wall and that's it what we saw with bran
was pretty cool because obviously we
haven't seen him in a long time and he's
clearly been doing some sort of training
with the three-eyed Raven we never
really knew what it was gonna be but the
sort of idea that he's kind of just
waltzing through the past you know as an
observer but is just kind of able to
walk through it is something that I hope
is kind of a tip of the iceburg thing
for what he's actually capable of doing
and not you know that'll obviously get
fleshed out over time I kind of really
like where Jamie is right now Jamie
Jamie is angry and into a degree we've
never seen before because you know even
when he was you know faced with
adversity and everything else he always
kind of had the swab kind of
swashbuckling a thing going on that's
gone he's just pissed now but you're
also seeing that contrasted with the
high Sparrow who as always is
wonderfully disarming I used that word
last time I'm gonna use it again it's
the perfect word for this guy it was a
tiny moment but I loved the resurrected
mountain just that guy against the wall
done and of course Tyrion with the
Dragons
yes all the yes yes to the moment yes to
what his little speech and what he said
and the way he delivered it yes to all
of it except and this is gonna be really
weirdly nitpicky something was off about
the faces of the Dragons they looked
fine most of the time but it's a few
times that it was a head-on shot I don't
know what it was I didn't like the look
I've been so that was all the stuff
that I really like then that gets us
more into the sort of neutral into the
not-so-great stuff Roose Bolton is dead
killed by Ramsay I'm not necessarily
gonna say that I would have called that
and it's kind of interesting cuz it did
seem like he obviously thought he did
and I legitimately did to think that
Roose could actually control or at least
point Ramsay at things and and you know
let him loose and he was never going to
be you know the victim of this guy in
the end he was maybe I was just blinded
to it the way that Roose himself was
buying into it so that moment kind of
worked but then they did what they so
often do with Ramsay which is take it
too far
all I needed was for him to say that guy
bring me lady Walder and the baby the
guy says you know the look of horror on
his face says yes my lord and that's it
stop there I know what's happening I
don't need to see any more than that but
of course you have to show me the rest
and show me that not only are we going
to kill a newborn baby it's gonna be
torn apart with wild dogs I didn't need
to know any of this that's something
that Ramsay's gonna do I get it but you
didn't have to show it so Balaam Greyjoy
killed by a character we've never seen
and so far as I can remember I have
never heard of I of course I say that as
a show watcher I'm sure the book readers
know who this guy is I mean I get that
he's Valens brother but I've got no
context for who this guy is
if him you know killing Balin and the
apparent - maybe look like he's gonna
trying to take over is a good thing or a
bad thing or a just shift I've gotten no
context for this event whatsoever so
it's just kind of a oh okay so now
that's a thing that has happened but of
course the quote-unquote big thing that
happens happens up at Castle black up at
the wall first we have Davos who talks
to lady Melisandre loved his little I
don't want to call it a pep talk or an
inspirational speech but I like what he
says to her I'm always liked him as a
character and that was a great moment
and then of course what happens is
what we all knew was going to happen
John is back and he is backed by the
exact means that I think most of us
figured he was gonna come back by so
this is obviously just okay we knew it
was gonna happen that should have
annoyed me but it kind of didn't I
actually oddly felt the tension like you
know thinking initially well of course
he's gonna come back and of course it's
gonna work but then something about just
the way that it's paced in the way that
it's shot and the music that's used that
it still pulled some tension out of me I
was kind of going he is coming back
right so I mean absolutely no surprise
when he did maybe a mild better relief
but oddly for something that was as big
about yet we all knew this was what was
gonna happen moment it still played
surprisingly well given that pretty much
everybody was predicting that he was
coming back to life probably better to
get it out of the way rather than string
us along too long that's actually
probably another part of the reason why
this scene worked for me because if if
it had been multiple episode weights and
then they string us along for that scene
in addition that would have been like Oh
for crying out loud
just to it already second episode of the
season you can string it along a little
bit it's fine I guess that's about it oh
the one other thing I forgot to mention
Aria so I you know guess she is going
back into the house of black and white
to learn more of the ways of the
faceless men and I'm actually starting
to get really mixed feelings about that
because you know they're hammering and
they're emphasizing over and over you
know you are nobody you are nobody or
nobody and I I get that that's part of
their deal and that's part of their
training but I I actually kind of don't
want to see our you go through this
because I I want Aria to get revenge I
want her to be I want her to be able to
kill more of the people who were on her
list I want her to get satisfaction but
I want that for Aria I don't want that
for no one and it does look like she has
to truly embrace and become what they're
saying in order to learn their ways I
worry about that bowl see where it goes
so as I said overall bit of a mixed
episode what was
was great stuff that I didn't think was
gonna work still work pretty well some
other stuff you know I didn't need or
just didn't mean anything so you know
that there were some dips there were
some weak boys there's still overall a
solid episode and you know excited to
see what comes next so have you seen the
latest episode of Game of Thrones what
were your thoughts on this thing
whatever they were drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
do not forget to like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks check
out the council of geeks podcast on
itunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned